let's bring in Nikki Haley now former
U.S ambassador to the UN in 2024
Republican presidential candidate and
live here in New York City on set with
us good to have you great to be here I
this this press briefing at the White
House took place during our hours here
yesterday we covered it live and many in
this country who have lived through this
pandemic might find it shocking to hear
John Kirby say this I'll get your
reaction
the president made
trying to find the origins of code a
priority right when he came into office
and he's got a whole of government
effort designed to do that
that there is not a consensus right now
in the US government about exactly how
covid started there is just not an
intelligence Community consensus can you
explain that why are we still here no
consensus and how does the U.S
department of energy know uh but the CIA
doesn't know or that there's not a
consensus what is going on here can we
at least have a consensus that when
covid broke out China closed their
borders to people coming in and they
opened their borders to everybody going
out they wanted everyone else to suffer
I think it came from the lab I don't
think it was malicious I think it was an
accident it's what they did after that
can we have consensus that they went to
the World Health Organization and asked
them to condemn the United States for
closing the Border can we have consensus
on the fact that they to this day have
never been held accountable for how
irresponsible it was for them to handle
it that's what we need to be talking if
you were sitting in the White House you
were President Biden how would you
respond to China accusing the U.S in
this moment of a smear campaign I've
dealt with China before whenever you
call them out they're very quick to turn
the tables what we need to do is start
holding them accountable enough talking
about what they did let's hold them
accountable let's start focusing on the
National Security aspects of the supply
chain and what we're relying on let's
start building up our military because
nothing scares China more than that
let's start telling our universities you
either take Chinese money or take
American money you don't take both and
let's start really getting our allies
together so that we can hold China
accountable the world suffered and
China's yet to pay a price and I know
that's what you are writing about in
your new op-ed you say I'll cut the
billions in foreign aid we send our
enemies and you lay out your case
exactly how you would plan to do that
I'm curious how you believe China would
respond to that if you're elected
president and if you cut off that
funding how would they respond it would
show China that we have a focus we give
46 billion in foreign aid and two
countries that say death to America or
countries that hate us we can't buy
friends China would notice that we were
paying attention why are we giving them
money for the environment it's just
ludicrous we shouldn't be giving them
one cent the idea that we give money to
Iraq and they're dealing with proxies
Iranian proxies that are saying death to
America the idea that we give it to
Zimbabwe and they're the most
anti-American African country out there
the idea that we're giving it to Cuba
and we've labeled them a state sponsor
of Terror why are we doing that don't
try and buy friends I started this at
the United Nations I created a book of
all 193 countries the second column was
the percentage of times they voted with
the U.S and against and the third column
was the amount foreign aid we gave them
and I gave that to president Trump and I
said we need to start being smart we
need to start being strategic he started
that by by stopping the 2 billion and
Aid we were giving to Pakistan that were
harboring terrorists trying to kill our
soldiers it sends the world a message
that we're paying attention that's the
focus of what cutting this foreign aid
to our enemies would do meanwhile back
here at home many voters are wondering
if this Administration is paying
attention to the historic inflation that
we're all living through and there's a
lot of smart People ambassador who have
been tasked with bringing those prices
down the Federal Reserve the
administration there are economists
Coast to Coast who are saying do this do
that this could fall in your lap if you
were elected president how do you tackle
inflation how do you bring prices down
for the American people without
inflicting too much pain on them well I
think first look at the fact that
Washington DC they're spending like
drunken Sailors they need to go on a
diet we need to realize that our federal
budget 15 of that is interest quit
borrowing money you don't have start
there look at the supply chain and say
why don't we start building more things
in America that's what we did in South
Carolina that's what we can do across
this country and then let's say okay
what are these other programs that we
need to start really taking a look at
and focus on that but start somewhere
the idea that Republicans and Democrats
started earmarks again really are you
going to pay 12 million for a baseball
stadium in New York when we've got
families who can't afford groceries it's
it's tone death uh Fox News polling
revealing this about the 2024 uh
presidential Republican nominee
preference among Republican primary
voters it's got Donald Trump at 43
percent Ron DeSantis 28 percent and you
Ambassador Haley 7 Mike Pence seven
percent Greg Abbott uh two percent and
Cheney at two percent what was your
response when you saw that is that where
you thought you were or where you think
you are we're just getting started we're
just getting started we had standing
room only hundreds of people came out in
Iowa and New Hampshire great progress
there we had thousands show up in South
Carolina people want someone who's going
to take this country in a New Gen in a
New Direction they don't want the old
status quo and they don't want the drama
let me just follow up on that that
because this was among Republican
primary voters how do you think you can
win over potential Republican voters by
talking about what real families are
going through my daughter is getting
married and I see how hard it is for her
to buy a home my son is in college and I
see how he's having to write papers he
doesn't believe to get an A we need to
go back to the basics on spending on
getting our education back on track and
get rid of all this woke stuff that's in
there close the borders make sure that
we are starting to have Street crime
handled again and look at the foreign
policy situation and don't ever allow
Americans to look at the sky and see a
Chinese Bible and looking back at them
it's time for us to get focused it's
time for us to get to work I did it as
Governor that took over a hurting State
I did it at the U.N and took the kick me
sign off of our backs I'm ready to do it
for our country all right Ambassador
Haley really good to have you here today
thanks so much we will be watching all
of it it feels like we're already full
you're full on in already right go to
nikkihaley.com that's where it's at all
right pleasure to have you here thank
you so much I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm able art and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis